Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today is another episode of Rawkode Live where
we take a look at the tools that
are help shaping and making the Kubernetes and
cloud native ecosystem
that little bit easier.
And today, we're doing an update video
from when we previously took a look at
Clue CTL, Clue Control, Clue Cuddle, Clue Cuddle,
whatever you prefer.
And to give us a overview and guided
tour of the new features and updates as
its creator and maintainer.
Kotablock.
Hey, man. How's it going? Long time.
Hey. Thanks for having me. Yep. Long time
ago, and quite some things have happened in
the Kluctlical ecosystem.
Alright. Well, for anyone who is not familiar,
let's just do a little bit of context
and background. So number one, tell us who
you are. And number two, tell us what
Kluctl is,
please.
So I'm
Alex
or known as CoderBlock. If you see me
online, I'm a developer, DevOps engineer.
Depends on what I'm doing right now.
I'm working on
on my Kluctl project mostly when I have
time.
It's an Opsource project providing you the ability
to
manage and deploy complex and simple Kubernetes deployments.
Yeah. That's what I do. I'm also a
freelancer,
but I
let's put it this way. If I would
have
the possibility to work on Kluctl
all day, I would do that.
But
family has to be
provided.
Always. Definitely. Yeah. Priority.
Alright. Well, thank you for sharing.
So
I can't remember when we did our last
video, but, you know, the
do you know?
I think it's about a year ago. A
year? Wow. Okay. Cool.
Quite some time. But I have been keeping
an eye on the project because
it's
it's just super useful. Right? Anyone who's not
familiar with the last video of the demo
or even a project, I'll put a link
in the comments once we get started today.
But just go check it out. It's a
tool that kinda tries to enable new features
that just aren't possible with Kube control
and I think everyone who's watched any video
on this channel knows of my distaste for
helm and how that we need
better tooling to handle the complexities of a
modern application deployment to Kubernetes.
You know, let's face it. We're not getting
away with 20 lanes of a deployment YAML,
six lanes of a service, and then ingress.
It's just not the way the applications run
on Kubernetes anymore.
And Kluctl had one of those secret features,
which I've been longing for for so long,
which is the ability to augment template and
rich those manifests from end cluster resources,
which was the highlight of the last video
for me.
However, you've been adding loads of new features.
I've been keeping a little bit of an
eye on the release notes, and you've been
kind enough to share the blogs and stuff
in the Discord server as well, which has
been really cool. And I won't give anything
away. Maybe you wanna give us the TLDR,
the overview, the highlights of what we're gonna
be taking a look at today.
Yep. So
the ham thing was kind of
a motivation for me as well in the
beginning, but it's very important. Kluctl is not
a replacement for Helm. It's really
kind of an interface to
Helm and customize
and more. So it's built on top of
it to manage helm and manage, customize
and so on.
Yeah,
I think maybe
best is if I do a small
slide where I give an overview about what
Kluctl is,
do it as fast as possible so that
we can go into,
yeah, live coding
as fast as we can. Okay.
Pull up your slide, and then I'll share
your screen.
Yes.
Give me a second.
Okay.
Alright. Live. Take it away.
So
as I said, I'm going to present
what Kluctl is.
Try to be as fast as possible. Best
is actually to look see video
that we made last year.
But yes, let's do it. So what is
Kluctl? Kluctl deployment Kluctl
is multiple things.
It allows you to define deployment projects
for simple, complex, small and large deployments. It
doesn't really matter. Deployments in the sense of
Kluctl are not Kubernetes
deployment objects.
They are like really the big picture, the
deployments
with everything.
Kluctl
is a CLI that allows you to deploy
these deployments in a push fashion.
This now the new things come.
The Kluctl GitOps controller allows you to deploy
stuff in a pull fashion
without losing the ability to do push
at the same time if you need to,
if there are ever any reason to do
that.
And the WebUI is also new, which gives
you visibility and control about your GitOps deployments
and also about your CLI deployments because both
are handled by the WebUI.
I'll continue to describe the projects
very fast.
So,
Kluctl deployment projects try to be as boilerplate
free as possible. That means you can always
start with a very small
deployment project, having the stuff that you need
to
do your current task. So for example, if
you just need to deploy NGINX,
you really just have one deployment YAML
that includes one deployment item, which is the
NGINX deployment
being a customization
or customized deployment.
And that's basically it. With these files, you
can already do your first deployment.
Then you see
CLI,
yeah, just to Kluctl deploy.
Very important, at this point, you already have
one of the most important features of Kluctl,
which is templating.
You can give the CLI arguments,
which are key value pairs.
Actually, key and
the value can be arbitrary YAML, so it
could be everything.
In this case, it's just a string, and
you can use it through simple Jinja templating
everywhere, including the customization YAML,
just everywhere.
David, if you have questions in between on
notes or something like that, just tell me
and I'll stop and explain something different. Yeah,
of course.
Also,
are built on top of each other. So,
as said, you try to start small.
And then, if you realize, for example, I
have a quite complex configuration when it comes
to the different
targets,
You can then use the next feature on
top of the
deployment project,
which is the Kluctl YAML defining your targets.
And the targets are kind of a shortcut
to what you would usually pass through the
CLI. For example, the arguments,
which you've seen before, we set environment
to
some value. We can do the same here
through the targets. And then the idea is
that instead of manually passing them time and
time again, you just do a deployment on
the target.
The idea is that you can also bind
targets to a context, for example. So you
can say that the simple target is always
deployed to cluster X,
while another target is deployed to cluster Y
with different configuration and so on.
Templating, as already mentioned, is kind of one
of the most important features. It's the glue.
It allows you to
use configuration
wherever you need it.
Of course, you should try to keep it
as simple as possible and not overdo the
templating because everyone knows how
templating can make life very hard. If you
look at hand charts, for example, it can
easily happen.
So in this case, let's say we need
replicas
being different on two different
targets. We could introduce that variable.
And
Okay, how to explain this?
Okay, I skipped one point. So
these variables can be passed through arguments,
since they are always prefixed with the args.
But you can also load variables and configuration
from files. There are multiple variable sources available.
File is a simple one. You can load
from git,
from different branches, tags, from master, main, whatever
you want. You can do HTTP
requests and load configuration from there. You can
use Vault, AWS secrets manager.
Azure is just being added right now and
so on.
It supports config maps as well. Right?
Sorry?
Does it can those configs not be loaded
from a config map? I think we we
did that last week. It can do that
as well. So you can also load
a YAML file from an existing config map
on the cluster
or from a secret, whatever you need. So
you can actually have information
inside the cluster to be used in the
deployments to do proper configuration of your targets.
For example, cluster name is a good example.
It doesn't make sense to have the cluster
name in all your deployment
projects or, for example, the base DNS name
where everything's served on. Instead of that, you
can have it in a conflict map on
the cluster, and every deployment can just load
it and use that for whatever it needs
it.
Yep. Perfect. Great feature.
Yeah. Makes things a lot easier. We had
that in the past where we had to
copy and paste all these configuration files to
all different
deployments that was
not very nice.
So in this example,
we have the deployment YAML.
In the old example, it was just including
the NGINX deployment. This time, it's also loading
some configuration.
And the idea is that templating is really
possible everywhere, so even while loading the configuration.
In this case, we have the target name.
If you look at the list of targets,
we always have the name of the target.
And we can, for example, already use it
to have some dynamic configuration loading. For example,
for the simple target, we would load
this configuration. For another target, we would load
this configuration
with having different replicas, for example.
And then, as described before, you do Closedale
deploy,
target another, and it will
also give you a diff and ask you
if you really want to apply it. And
then you say yes or no, and then
you actually apply it.
Next thing is
you want to say Sorry. No, no. Was
just saying cool. I don't mean to throw
you off there. Sorry. Yeah, we have a
little bit of lag, unfortunately. Network is really
bad in this office right now.
So
order and dependencies are easy to master.
It turned out that so this was also
one of the reasons why I even started
this project.
If you use Helm, just Helm,
you get into
problems when it comes to orchestration of all
the different Helm charts that need to be
installed.
There are solutions. Helm5, for example, can, I
think, define order? You can also do it
with Flux
by defining dependencies between Helm releases
and so on.
In ClueCDL,
it's
quite easy, actually. You just have the list
of deployments, and that's the order.
It's that easy.
The idea is that everything that you give
here is deployed in parallel until it reaches
a barrier.
Then it waits for everything to finish that's
above the barrier and then it continues with
the next one. So this
is all you need to have order and
dependency management.
So a good example is,
very often, have to deploy namespaces first,
and you cannot start to deploy something into
these namespaces
before the namespace is deployed.
Same with custom resource definitions. Selium, for example,
provides some. You cannot do anything before the
custom resource definitions are deployed. I mean, you
cannot deploy
the custom resources before the CRDs are deployed
and so on.
Hooks can be used to
even have more advanced
control about your deployments. For example,
Selium, even though stuff is
applied to the cluster, it's still not ready.
So you might need a hook that waits
for it to actually completely become ready. So
you can also do that with Hooks, for
example.
So
next thing is this is new since the
last time we did the last video.
And not really. At that time, I already
had an implementation of GitOps,
which tried to integrate itself into the Flux
ecosystem, but I realized pretty fast that
Kluctl does not depend on Flux and should
not depend on Flux.
And it should actually completely live on its
own. So the solution was to implement the
Clue Cutter controller,
which now completely lives on its own. It
provides a Clue serial deployment, CRD.
The idea is that the CRD implements the
same interface as the CLI.
So whatever you are
used to provide to the CLI, for example,
passing arguments,
passing tags, passing
options like dry run mode or
if it should wait or not can also
be passed through the Kluctlesteo deployment. So it
tries to mirror it one to one.
Yeah, here's a list of what you can
so, yeah, the target name, for example, it's
in the CRD.
You can define it through the CRD and
the CLI arguments.
Yeah.
Encryption is supported and can also be configured
through the CRD.
Very important,
if you start to use GitOps with the
Cluster Deployment CRD, you can still
use push based
deployments. So you can still use the CLI.
And you can mix it if you need
to if it makes sense, depends on your
use case. In my opinion, it makes sense.
For example, if you want to have
a dev environment where you want to have
iterations,
where you just want to try something out,
deploy it, try something out, deploy it.
And for prod, for example, you want to
have a proper GitOps workflow.
So the idea is that the same projects
allow you do
both.
Here's a simple example of a close to
the old deployment GitOps
deployment asset.
You give it the source, so the URL
of the Git repository,
some subdirectory,
target name, context.
So the default context means deploy to the
same cluster where the controller is running. You
can also give it context
to actually a full kube config through a
secret to another cluster.
You can tell it if it should prune
or not, if it should delete the whole
deployment on deletion of the
custom resource
and so on.
So you can
look at the Kluctl deployment. It will give
you some basic information. For example, if there's
some drift, it will do internal drift detection,
like figure out if something
has been changed by someone else than the
controller.
This is currently not implemented. I plan it
for one of the next releases.
Then you will also be able to trigger
a forced redeployment
through the CLI.
Currently, it's only possible through the WebUI
or through some manipulation of the custom resource.
The WebUI is also new.
I'm going to show it later as well.
The idea is that it shows you the
projects, so basically, git projects,
the targets
and the historical results from
commands that you did on these targets.
The UI is not the most beautiful UI
of the world. That happens when a developer
does React.
So if someone wants to improve it, I'm
happy for contributors.
Zwap UI is easy to start with. It
does not
you don't have to install it. I mean,
of course, it's recommended to install it because
then you have other features like OADC integration.
But if you just want to try it
out or
there is no way to install it somewhere
properly,
you can just run it through krlutecdlWebUI
run and it will just run locally
and connect to the remote cluster.
Multi cluster support is
implemented in some way, but it's still a
lot of stuff to do there. So it's
also very important. The UI is very early
stage, so a lot of improvements and features
will come.
But it's already good enough to
be of some
good help in daily business.
Yeah. That's it for now. Demo time.
Should I directly switch to demo time, or
do you want to say something or ask
something first?
No. Let's go straight into the XAML. I
have questions, but we'll bring them up as
we we work through the
the rest of Okay.
I prepared a little bit. I tried to
not prepare too much. What I prepared is
a Bootstrap deployment
and some applications
that we are going to deploy into a
kind cluster, a local kind cluster.
Reason I prepared this is in the previous
video, I did a full setup of a
project. So if you want to learn how
to do that, best is to watch that
video first.
And here, we assume that you already know
how to do that or
at least know how to figure out how
to do that.
So
let's open the terminal.
As said, I'm going to deploy this to
a local kind cluster.
I have some configuration here for the kind
cluster, which is a
one control plane to worker node setup running
locally in my Docker
setup.
To showcase
the capabilities of Clue CDL, I decided to
not give it a CNI
and disable KubeProxy
completely. That means we get a
naked cluster. It's not completely naked because it
still has CSI installed,
but at least there is no CNI,
and that means it's actually useless without
doing proper bootstrapping.
Let's create a cluster.
Of course, I'm in the wrong folder.
Okay.
So you can ask your questions in between
while we have we will have some waiting
times
when stuff starts up after bootstrapping.
Yeah. Well, I'm a big fan of people
deploying useless slash broken clusters.
So, you know, always fun to see.
Now you
said that
let's go back to the flux stuff you
were talking about, Eric. You said that Kluctl
tried to kind of integrate there, but you
decided that it should be a dependency about
your own controller. Yep. I mean, I'm just
curious.
Like, that's that's a mission. Right? Like, even
using something like controller runtime is still a
lot of effort and work that needs to
go into this. And as we've seen from
the example output, it does drift control and
status checks and all of this like Yep.
So what realized is that all the
controller related stuff, it's not that much actually
because the real
work has gone into CluSDL itself. So all
the drift detection, everything, all the features that
are in some way important
is already implemented
through Kluctl because all the features that you
get through the GitOps controller,
you already have them through the CLI.
So there was
at that point, it was not so much
effort to implement the
important features.
There was one dependency
in regard to Git repositories. So Flux uses
dedicated
CRDs
for
source management. So you have your Git repositories
to
actually load the code, and then you refer
it in your customizations,
for example.
And that's, for example, something that is not
really comparable to Kluctl because Kluctl does its
own
source
management or source control.
It does its own checking out of and
cloning of repositories.
It has git include. So if you have
maybe you remember the list of deployment items,
So far, just had
path entries, but there are also git
includes possible. So you can load git repositories
and have deployments scattered around
through multiple
repositories.
So this was all stuff
reusing stuff from Plux would not give any
benefit
because I would still have to do my
own stuff inside
ClueCL.
In the end, I decided to
completely
go on my own in that regard.
Unfortunately, I don't have an example of getting
oh, I actually have.
Maybe let's jump to that first before you
can oh, no. Let's do the Bootstrap deployment.
And while all this starts up, because it
takes some time, I'm going to explain the
Bootstrap deployment a little bit.
So as said, we now have a
naked
kind cluster locally.
It's not completely naked because it still has
CSI, for example, installed to local pass provisioner.
CoreDNS is preinstalled, but it's all not running
because the nodes are not ready.
We have three nodes. They are all not
ready because the networking is just not up
and running.
With the Bootstrap deployment,
we can now just
run ClueCDL Deploy.
It will do a dry run first.
The dry run, in this case, fails because
it cannot dry run stuff if some stuff
is missing. For example, the namespace has not
been created yet,
so it can try to simulate some of
that stuff, but it's not perfect.
So even so it tells me there are
errors, I know that if I actually apply
it, it will work after some time.
So I said, yes, we are going to
deploy this now. What's happening now is it
has applied already a few resources,
and then it encountered
Helm hook because Helm hooks are fully supported
and now waits for the hook to finish.
You should be able to see that on
the cluster.
So if you look at the pods so
you already see, Cilium
pods are starting up.
The Hubble generator
job is already running, which is the hooks
that we are currently waiting for.
And as said, this will take some time
until
all this is green.
So
maybe jump to the git includes that I
just mentioned. So the Bootstrap deployment
has
multiple deployment items that are being installed. Selium,
then it does the barrier.
Selium wait is a
just a small pot
that is kind of
to so that the deployment knows
the cluster is really up and running because
when the first pot can be started, we
know everything is fine. So I use a
simple hook to
make sure that we don't continue before it's
really up and running, the cluster.
Some namespaces.
In this case,
just the Ingress NGINX namespace that we can
later install the Ingress controller.
We have a barrier
in this case because we cannot install the
ingress controller before the namespace is actually there.
Then we have cert manager. I'm installing it,
but I'm not really using it in this
example because I don't have external DNS setup
and everything.
But
yes, maybe it's a good example to just
show that we do Helm here, for example.
So SAP Manager is actually a deployment item
that
pulls in a Hound chart. We give it
the repo,
chart name, chart version, release name, namespace.
This is I'm not going to explain this
part.
The good thing is
you can use templating here already, at least
partially, not everywhere, but partially. For example, I
could here already do some
fancy
templating to have a dynamic namespace, which we
actually will do later.
So what do we have here?
Yeah. I prepared the bootstrap deployment two hours
before the session, so it's not perfect.
When in run it again.
Sorry? When in run it again. Exactly.
And it tells us two objects are missing.
The SelumNetworkPolicy
did not finish for the template controller, which
I'm also going to show later.
The ingress did not finish. Probably, it actually
told us the
the webhook of the ingress controller was not
ready. So I forgot some barrier or some
weight readiness there.
So as you already said, let's just retry
it.
And this time, it should actually just start
up.
Yes. So it looks healthy now. Yeah.
It's now again waiting for the Selium weight
pot.
And it's finished as well now.
So yeah, it looks good. And now ingress
controller is being
deployed. So the hooks are actually rerun.
And
we are done. Everything is green now.
In this case,
I didn't check why it's happening.
Cellium is adding some
labels
into deployment that I don't know why. I
didn't check why it did that. But I
can see it. That's already nice. So I
know something is interfering with my deployments,
and I would be able to debug that
now.
So we have a
usable cluster now.
Very important, we have an Ingress controller and
we have the ClusterDealController
running.
I'm going to show the ClusterDealController
later.
What I can show already now is the
WebUI.
As said,
you can just
run it locally
via Kluctl dot slash WebUI run.
The default port is already used, so I
have to use another one right now.
And there it is.
So it's just using the current context, connecting
to the cluster,
reading all the necessary information, and it already
knows that there were some command line invocations,
the ones that we've just seen.
And we can
get some information about it. For command line
information, there's for command line
invocations, there's not much information available. But
what you can see is at least what
has happened. As an example,
what you have just seen in the
CLI output can also be seen here. So
the diff with the strange IDs being replaced.
We see that the two new objects have
been created that we've seen.
And we would see basically everything that we
see in the CLI here.
You can also see ODA results.
This is the first invocation we had. We
see a lot of new objects.
No changed objects.
We can also
open the complete
project here
and see all the rendered objects, applied objects,
on cluster objects and so on as an
example.
Let's see.
What do we have here? Here's some config
map.
And we see this is the version that
was rendered.
This is the version that got applied.
This is the remote version before we applied
it, so you can do some debugging here
to figure out what happened.
Yeah.
Any So because this wasn't installed, the way
that this is working right now is that
if you, on your local machine, have access
to the Kubernetes cluster and enough permissions to
be able to read,
I guess, the clear control custom resources, the
status fields, and so forth, then it's able
to just represent all of that on a
UI and you can just view it. But
like you said, like, you
don't get the OIDC integrations.
If you need a privileged user locally on
your own machine to be able to access
it. Okay. Yeah. I love that it shows
the command line implications, and it's not just
restricted to the clear control deployment CRD, which
is pricey.
That's what I tried to explain. The all
the functionality of Kluctl is part of Kluctl
itself. It's not part of the controller. The
controller is really just on top of it,
like an interface to what it already provides.
So
it doesn't really make a difference
what caused these
deployments. It's the same in the end.
Regarding the Z Chelsea command line, there are
some improvements that are planned because if you
have a lot of deployments and we have
clusters with a lot of deployments
where we also do a lot of manual
stuff because in daily work, it's required
for us,
it can the command line
cards can kind of it gets too much.
So there needs to be some some improvements
and filtering capabilities and so on. With regards
to the command line stuff, does it tell
you the user?
I know Kubernetes doesn't really have a concept
of user. Right? But it does have, like,
token,
has authentication.
Has any of that propagated into the history?
No.
Not yet. And I'm not sure if that's
even a good thing because
data protection in at least in Germany and
the EU,
not sure if they would be happy with
the I don't know. I'm not a lawyer,
so I don't want to
put personal information into some clusters.
Doesn't feel Makes sense.
Okay.
So I've shown you the
locally run version now.
I can also install it, as explained.
The Bootstrap deployment actually does that. So we
have a Kluctl
include here. Or maybe I can the list
of deployment items has different types of deployment
items. The most basic one is
referenced through path,
which is just a list of manifests or
it can be a customized deployment or it
can be a hound chart that is being
installed.
Then there are includes. Includes means
the path that I provide here contains another
Clue CDL deployment. So you can kind of
continue here the same way you did in
the root deployment. You again have a deployment
YAML,
and you have a list of deployment items,
and you could have the simple
items with the path here again. That's what
we have here, for example,
and so on. So you can have it
as deep as you want.
And the idea is that if you have
configuration
values loaded, you can pass them into sub
deployments as well,
as deep as you want. And at any
level, you can introduce new configuration that is
based on the one that was passed before
and so on. So you can
do
some nice things there.
In this case, we have a git include.
That's what I mentioned before.
This one is pointing to the public Kluctl
repository into the subdirectory install controller, which contains
the Kluctl deployment
that has all the necessary stuff to deploy
the ClueSlide controller.
Same with the WebUI.
This gives the basic installation of the controller.
For the controller, that's enough, actually. It doesn't
need anything else.
The WebUI,
because it's a very plain deployment
with just a service and no ingress and
stuff like that,
I think in most cases will require some
additional
stuff, which we see here.
So
we have an ingress also deployed after this,
which just gives us the web UIs through
the ingress controller.
I'm using local host TV,
which always
resolves to localhost, so one dot seven zero
zero one.
So if I go to that URL
where is my Chrome browser?
Why does it not work?
Okay. I first have to go to the
console and then
it works. I have just oh, okay. It's
already working. Great. So this is the UI
installed to the cluster.
If you install it without OIDC, it will
create some basic users, two users, one admin
user and one viewer user.
We are going to use the admin user.
The password
is,
by default, pre generated
by the WebUI itself and written into
the WebUI secret.
And, yeah, you see the same as before
with the difference that you can log out
now. So
for now on, I will use the installed
version instead of the local version.
Cool.
What else?
So,
as explained, we now have a basic cluster
up and running. We have bootstrapped it. Oh,
what? No, I do not want to move.
Okay, so we have the bootstrapped thing.
Now the idea is,
of course, that's
not enough. You, of course, also want to
have some applications deployed to it. I prepared
two applications, Podinfo and PotatoHat,
which we are going to deploy now.
Let's start with
maybe
Potato Head. It doesn't really matter.
This one is using
plain manifests
everywhere.
So we have a root deployment
that includes the
sub deployment of potato services.
This one
has some simple deployment items with customized deployments
having plain
manifests with some templating,
not too much,
just the stuff that is really necessary.
Sorry, I need to change something.
Yeah, plain manifest, nothing special.
Namespace again
with order being properly managed through a barrier.
And another special thing,
I called it the template service. This is
a deployment item
that has a little bit more of templating.
And the idea is that you can include
this one multiple times with different
configuration.
So the original potato services project
has,
I don't know, maybe like
seven microservices,
and each one has its own folder
kind of containing the same files. And I
changed it to have just one template
manifest folder,
and I'm including it multiple times. So for
example, for the hat, I am including it,
giving it some configuration. As said, on any
level in the deployment, you can introduce new
configurations that are then available from for the
deployment in question and all the sub deployments
of that.
So here, for example, we give it this
configuration.
Then we have the
leg deployment,
left leg and
later the right leg.
Some conditionals can be used. For example, if
you just want to have legs when legs
are actually enabled through the configuration.
So if this would be false, this would
be completely skipped.
What do we have here? Just an example
that you can also use JSON because it's
a subset of YAML.
Makes things
shorter in some cases.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe the configuration,
a little bit.
So this one is using a pattern that
I really like. We have some common configuration
loaded through the root deployment.
The common configuration,
for example, gives us some configuration about the
replicas for the different microservices.
It tells us that legs are by default
enabled because we need legs.
Here, we have
some image configuration,
which can, as you can see, pass from
the outside world as well through the
-a argument.
Base DNS,
which we are then using in ingresses.
Then the idea is that after loading the
command configuration, we can load more specific configuration.
And as already explained before, we can already
use templating here. So, for example, we say
that the
config file with the name envtype is loaded
here as well. The idea is that this
is merged.
So this one is loaded, building up the
templating context,
then this one is loaded. This one can
already use everything from the first one. So
everything that was defined here can be used
here.
And everything that this one defines
that was already there is overwritten,
so you can stack it on top of
each other.
So what do we have here? We have
the non prod deployment, which just overrides the
hat replicas.
Maybe we need some more hats in
non prod environments for whatever it is. We
don't need legs.
And for prod, we say front end should
be a little bit
more replicated.
We can also change the image here,
which is overriding what we've defined here.
So you can do whatever you want. It's
completely
free to free.
Cool.
So
I think I explained enough.
Let's deploy that thing.
This one has currently
defined two targets, test and prod.
They are currently deploying to the same cluster
to the same context, which is the one
configured right now. I could also say that
the context is fixed to, for example, this
one, which is the same right now. But
I think you can imagine what I could
do here. I could say that, okay, this
one should always go to this context and
so on
so that
errors are not happening so easily.
These are the arguments that you have maybe
seen here already,
which are being overwritten.
And, yeah, let's just do it.
Again, it tells us what it will do,
a lot of new objects.
We are happy with that. We say yes,
and we
see them appear.
A lot of potato hat services.
And two hats. And
two hats, yeah, as promised.
I can also do a prod deployment now.
Maybe one important thing is the namespace is
templated,
so we can deploy to the same cluster
multiple times just by using the target name
as a prefix.
And now we have another potato head.
I'm not going to open the ingress now
because it's nothing
nothing special here. Or do you want to
see it?
No. But I would like to see the
web UI again.
Oh, yeah. Sure. That's actually more interesting. So
more command line entries.
So this is still the cluster bootstrap. Nothing
has happened here. But we see that there
is a new project with tune new
targets,
prod and test,
both invoked through the command line and
actually see different
amount of new objects. That's probably because one
has lags enabled and the other one not.
So if you would check this, we would
see that this one
has lags and the other one does not
have lags.
Now maybe
to showcase the UI a little bit more,
let's
actually change something here.
Let's say non prod has
now three heads,
and we need some legs.
So we
realized not having legs is a bad idea.
So I'm redeploying test again. And as mentioned
before, it would show what it's going to
do. It tells us four new objects.
One has changed,
and this is the diff of the changed
objects.
This is what you would have expected.
So we say yes, and now it confirms
this is what I actually did.
And the UI is not popping up again.
And here, we see another card on top
of this one here, and we see four
new objects and one changed object.
We can see the legs have appeared and
the replicas have been changed.
We can now also undo what we did
here.
And now it's
also very interesting.
We have created new objects, and now these
objects are not in the deployment anymore because
we changed the configuration in a way that
makes them disappear.
That also means we usually want them to
get removed from the cluster as well. Kluctl
edu will detect that these objects are orphan
and
ask you actually,
not now, but I can do a prune
call afterwards to actually clean up the cluster.
So Bart, we can see replicas back to
two. We say, yes, we are happy with
that. And then we also say we actually
want to get rid of these orphan objects.
And then they are gone.
And the UI
will then show us that two commands have
been invoked. This is the first one
where we see the replicas.
It tells us even though
it did a few changes, it also detected
a few orphans.
But we then immediately
handled that situation and deleted them through the
prune invocation.
Nice. I like that.
So
let's keep it this way with the potato
hat.
Yeah. I think I have shown enough when
it comes to the push based
stuff.
How do you think?
Yeah. That's great. Definitely. Okay.
Cool. Then let's start with something new.
This is something I have not prepared. I'm
going to do it on the fly.
The good thing is you can manage ClueCDL
deployments through ClueCDL.
Makes sense because
why not?
So what we are going to do now
is
define Is that mean can do a handoff,
like where you do ClueControl
deploy locally,
which has a ClueControl deployment that then brings
itself under management. Right? Exactly.
That's what we actually do
all the time. So we have kind of
one entry point into GitOps. We deploy it
once, and then GitOps takes over.
So let's start with the podinfo
deployment this time.
Let's open the documentation
and figure out how to do that because
I cannot remember by myself.
I think I have it here already. So
kluctl.io
is the website having documentation
and examples and blog posts and tutorials.
And, of course, also the documentation for the
GitHub stuff.
So let's take this as an example
and
put it in here
and go through all the individual fields. So
this is pod info
interval.
Let's have a smaller one so that we
don't have to wait that long.
Let's
use this Git repository, but we use
the HTTP version, HTTPS,
I mean.
And
the path is an apps podinfo.
In most cases, we just have the path
submitted because we have the deployment on the
root level already.
Timeout
means
how
long
to wait until cancel everything. This is very
important
if you are waiting for stuff.
For example, the cluster bootstrap
would need a higher time out, if you
would like to do that.
Let's
deploy the target test first. Context is default,
which means deploy to the cluster
or the context that we are currently running
inside.
Is default the
default value? Can you just delete that lane?
No.
In that case, it will use the context
defined in the project.
In that case,
I think there is no context defined.
So let's assume here there would be a
context that would use this one, which will
not work because the
GitOps controller does not know about that context.
You would have to explicitly
give it a kubeconfig that has that context.
In most cases,
we don't do that. In most cases, we
just deploy to the default context, which means
into the cluster we are on right now.
We have one special case
where we have a cluster API
creating clusters
and then bootstrapping the workload cluster that is
being created
with the help of the kube configs that
is created by Cluster API.
So that's the case where, for example, we
would actually give it the real context name
and a kube config
Config with a secret ref and key and
so on. It's a little bit like what
you know from Kluctlx maybe
if you want to support multiple clusters.
Yeah. By default, pruning is disabled. Deletion is
disabled.
Let's ignore this one. I'm going to explain
that later.
But it makes sense to enable it. It's
disabled because it's really dangerous if you don't
know what you're doing. If you make a
mistake, you can easily just delete your whole
cluster. I think everyone who does GitOps
has made that experience in the past,
and it's painful.
So
default is to be on the safe side
and be very explicit about
these dangerous things.
And I think
that's it.
So you asked for the handoff. We could
do that. I could
put that into the podinfo deployment, for example,
and send to the handoff, but it would
be a little bit more
complicated.
So let's,
in this case, do it a little bit
easier.
Let's have its own deployment.
What I like to do is have a
directory structure, for example,
clusters.
Then we have
directories called
like, the clusters are named. And what you
can then do is
deployment.
So, we can do now something like
clusters
target.
Name.
And now,
we can create new clusters
based on directory names.
But we, of course, still need the targets,
so let's have a target named
kind, kind.
Oh, wait, let's
oh, yeah. That's what I did, actually.
We need a discriminator,
which is just
let's say GitOps. As the discriminator is used
to so everything that is created by Kluctl
gets labels attached that allow it to identify
everything that belongs to this deployment.
So actually, it should be
something like that.
So if you have multiple targets, for example,
you need different discriminators so that pruning actually
identifies the correct objects that need to be
pruned from a target or a deployment.
It's optional, it's recommended because without that, you
cannot do pruning.
So
let's put this into this one now.
And I think that's it. We now have
a
deployment that is responsible for
Clusidl deployments.
We can do the handoff here as well
now in a different way, but maybe let's
do that later.
So
let's go into GitOps.
We should now be able to
what is wrong? File is not a directory.
So what did I do wrong now?
Kluctl
dot Yamal.
Oh.
It's in the wrong directory. Right?
Oh, no. Looks like No. It's not it's
not the correct one.
So Kluctl dot Yamal.
K. This must be a very stupid mistake.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, your target name? No.
No. It's okay. I thought it was supposed
to be kind prod, but
maybe it's kind kind.
Yeah. In this case, we are referring
cluster names.
In this case, I just have this one.
Because we are managing GitOps on cluster level,
that cluster can deploy multiple targets and so
on. But it's
all up to you how you want to
manage this.
What
is wrong here?
Missing resource meter data.
Oh, wait. You've called the failed Kluctl dot
YAML, not dot Kluctl dot YAML.
Mhmm.
Okay. Did it start with a dot?
This one started with a dot. Yes. Alright.
Okay.
Target kind kind.
I don't get it.
Why
does this not work?
Let's
okay.
So it's already on the root level.
Dot Kluctl dot
Yamal.
Yeah.
This is really stupid right now.
Deployment.
What the
okay.
As assumed, it's a very stupid mistake.
Then if I do workday, because I didn't
spot it.
So, yeah, easy one. Oh, we already see
I made a mistake. I deployed to the
default namespace, which is usually not what you
want to do.
Let's use the
Kluctl
system namespace.
Very important,
the controller uses service accounts
for RBAC. So if you deploy
if you add a Clustered deployment to a
namespace, it will, by default, use the service
account of that namespace
to do the actual
deployment to the cluster.
You can override that
by giving it another service account name, but
usually, you don't need that. This means that
I cannot use the default namespace, for example,
because the service account doesn't even have the
necessary permissions to do the deployment.
I could introduce that by introducing a special
service account with all the necessary roles and
bindings and so on. But to make things
easier, I'm doing it this way now.
So now we see it's in the correct
namespace,
and let's go for it.
No error. That's always good.
And
something has happened.
That's not how I wanted to show it,
but we see that an ingress immediately appeared.
So on K9S, we should see the Kluctl
deployment object now.
And we see some information. We see the
name. Dry run is disabled. It was deployed
a few seconds ago. It's not ready.
It will only become ready when all the
deployments are green,
which will happen maybe in the next reconciliation
loop. So when one minute is over, it
will probably turn ready.
Yes, we already see it here. Validate has
failed.
No drift, which is good.
And let's see the same in the UI.
And what you see here now is
a new project appearing
with a target,
the podinfo test,
status information
and
the deployment that happened in the controller already.
And here, it's the same. We can see
the changes,
some new objects, nothing special.
And now, as mentioned, next reconciliation loop
turned its green because all the pods are
ready now.
We can do some stuff with that deployment
now. For example, we can force a reconciliation.
So it's happening before the one minute has
passed. We can tell it to validate now.
We can tell it to deploy now.
In this case, nothing will happen because nothing
has changed. It tells us result is empty,
nothing happens.
We can prune, but again, nothing will happen.
If we need to do some very strange
stuff
and we are afraid that GitOps will kill
us,
so for example, some refactorings in secret repositories,
we can always suspend
the deployments, so nothing bad will happen.
We can resume it again.
And
yeah, now let's actually do some
changes.
Actually,
let's
do something different.
So we have podinfo
test.
Let's also introduce podinfo
prod to the same cluster.
I'm not going to rename this one because
deleting and recreating this one means that due
to the delete being true, stuff is actually
getting deleted and recreated,
which in this case is probably Okay, but
let's not risk that.
So
prod,
and I think that's it.
It tells us when new object is being
created.
Yes.
And in the UI, we should see it
appear.
And we see another target, the prod target,
having some new objects and so on.
I
think we can
in this case, it maybe makes sense to
actually show the ingress.
So we have the test pod info
and the prod pod info, test and prod.
Let's
open this one.
I have to switch to HTTP because
and we have a green one, and
we have a blue one.
And this is simply because
we have
the same setup here, where we load
some configuration based on ENV type.
And here,
we just change the color depending on prod
or non prod.
So prod uses the default configuration and non
prod overrides the color to be green. So
default configuration is to be
blue, which comes through
this one.
What
else can we show now?
Yeah. Let's actually do some changes. So let's
say
let's say we want reds
on non prod,
and
we want
replicas on props to be different.
Okay, I made it a little bit unnecessary
complex here to showcase some stuff in the
past. We can also override that value through
the ARCs. As I described, the Kluctl deployment
is just an interface to the CLI. So
I can also just say
not an interface to the CLI, but it
has the same interface as the CLI.
So we know we can here give it
podinfo
replicas,
and let's say we want three replicas.
Let's hope this is not the default because
then nothing will happen. Yes, it's not the
default.
So what we did now is
we changed the non prod deployment.
We did not touch the prod deployment,
but we changed the GitOps object for prod,
which means it still has an effect.
Hope it's not too complicated what I'm doing
here.
Let's
just do a VIP commit.
And if you wait a minute now,
we should see that the WebUI
will update both,
actually.
But as I'm
I don't want to wait, I'm telling it
to reconcile now.
Nothing happens.
Oh, okay. No.
Okay.
No change.
Oh, actually, it didn't change.
No wait.
So
test has been deployed.
Something has changed. We can now verify that
it has become red.
It is already red. Funny.
So it reloaded itself, actually. Interesting.
This one, it's interesting that this one has
no effect now,
even though
it should. Let's force the deployment.
Didn't do anything.
Interesting. I might have missed something. So is
it really correct what I'm doing here?
So common setting says axe pod info dot
replicas.
Did actually no, I actually have to deploy
that, okay. So
I made a thinking around now. I assumed
that changing this would actually already have an
effect on the GitOps
deployment. But as the GitOps deployment itself are
not managed by GitOps right now, I could
introduce that, but maybe that's too much for
now.
Of course, nothing's happening. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. I get it. I mean, you could
do it. That's what you asked with the
handoff. I can now act maybe let's do
it. Why not?
Let's have a GitOps YAML.
Call it
GitOps
target is
kind to kind. Contact is default because we
are still deploying to the same cluster as
the controller is running on.
Let's do pruning and deletion. And
very important, I now really have to commit
and push it first, because if I deploy
that,
the controller will delete everything immediately because it's
not in Git.
That's the fun part about GitOps sometimes.
So now
I deploy it once
to activate the GitOps deployment. So we now
see there is a new Kluctl deployment being
the GitOps deployment.
The other one has changed now with the
thing that I was confused about.
And we should now see
so
prod has been deployed, nice.
Replicas has been changed, as expected.
Of course, we will not see anything different
here now.
And we should see the GitOps deployment.
Nice.
It tells us that there is a validation
error.
Ah, okay.
When it did the validation, the reconciliation was
not ready yet, not done yet for the
new
for one of the deployments, so it tells
us.
So it's red now. I need to drink
something.
Very cool.
So now, if I would have done what
I did before, it would actually happen. So
if I would change the pod info, Kluctl.com,
then
stuff would actually happen.
Not sure if I should showcase that now.
By the way, how long are we already
streaming?
Like, an hour? Yeah. An hour. What
do you think? How long should we continue?
I mean, I have change and then we'll
see what happens.
Okay. The one thing that's popped into my
head, right, is that,
you know, when it comes to the handoff,
I probably want as few pieces of YAML
as possible. Now I know that in
GetOps clusters can kind, we've got the GetOps.YAML,
the pod info prod, the pod info test.
But, I mean, I could just have one
global
deployment that does a whole bunch of includes.
Right? And then I don't have to Yeah.
Yeah.
So
for example,
we started with having a lot of Git
repositories being involved, doing hand off, hand off,
hand off, and
it can get really
hard to follow, let's put it this way.
We've just seen a very simple example. We
changed something and we're very confused that nothing
happens.
And this can become a lot worse if
too many Git repositories are involved
that, at the same time, are deployed through
Clusively Deployment Objects. So the other way is,
as you already mentioned,
just using git includes. So you have one
entry point,
and this one is doing everything.
But it all depends.
Sometimes deployments take so long that you actually
don't want to mix them with other stuff.
So it really depends on on your need.
Yeah. I guess it it depends where your
risk appetite is as well. Like, if you
just wanna automate everything and you'll lower it,
then sure have one. But maybe if you
wanna minimize the blast radius for errors and
having multiple
CRDs,
multiple deployments and isolating them to either get
repositories, CRDs, whatever is a better approach. My
risk adversity is
low. I don't care if I blow up
my production cluster, so I generally just go
for the was the minimal amount of Yamal
I need to approach. Yeah. This is cool.
Like, we've seen some really come up to
the project. The web UI is great. I
know you were
kind of self deprecating yourself and say this
is what happens when a developer does a
design or a UI, but to honest, look,
it's super functional. And it does does exactly
what it needs to do. It shows you
the changes and it gives you the ability
to interface with the controller for the revalidation,
for the reconciliation,
drift detection. Like, that is just perfect.
The controller itself is doing its job in
the background. Like, these are some wonderful updates
to an already pretty fantastic project. So I
I applaud you. Good work.
Thank you.
So I don't know if you have anything
else to show,
but maybe if you don't, you could just
tell us like,
what is what's next in your wish list
of ideas for click control? Where are you
going? What's going to be happening?
Yeah. Take it away.
So I
had
I planned to show more,
especially the
template controller, but this will take another thirty
minutes or so. Maybe that's already too much
for this session.
Maybe just a few words about that.
Yeah, sure. So in the ClueSlideal
ecosystem, there's also the template controller,
which is independent
from the ClueSlideal controller, so you can install
and run it on its own without any
dependencies into Kluctl.
And what it allows you is to take
arbitrary
on that page? Sorry.
Sorry?
Can you zoom in on that that YAML?
Do what? Zoom. Make it bigger. Zoom?
Sure.
If I figure out how to do that.
Command plus. Command
plus. Yes. Finally. Perfect. Thank you.
So,
yes, the idea is the object template takes
a matrix of input resources,
which is whatever you like, for example, a
config map or a secret
or a Clusiddial deployment or
a
Git projector or GitHub comment list, GitLab and
so on,
and
take a list of templates and then use
templating to generate an arbitrary set of other
objects.
It has multiple
use cases.
The original use case why I started that
was to have something like preview environments,
a little bit like what you know from
application sets from ArgoCity.
So,
for example, you have the git projector object,
which
internally
clones the git project and makes
parts of the repository
available
through the status of that
resource.
So if you apply that,
the resource will get the status populated with,
for example, a list of branches, a list
of file contents, whatever you configure it.
Based on that, you can use that as
the input into the object template
and tell it to generate, for example, Clusidl
deployment objects
based on the list of branches that you
found in some repository.
This basically allows you to do preview environments
depending on the
repositories
branches.
You can do the same,
but based on GitHub
pull requests. So instead of reading branches in
Git repositories, you can also tell it to
use the GitHub API
to
get a list of pull requests
and, based on that, create
preview environments.
Then you can use
GitHub comment objects to actually post some comments
into the pull requests that you just listed
and templated and so on.
Yes, the idea is that you can build
up your
whatever you
need in regard to dynamic creation of environments.
So this is one use case.
It's a pretty complicated use case.
It needs a lot of
YAML to set it up, a lot of
these thingies.
But in the future, I hope I can
provide some good example starting points how to
implement
preview environments with that. Another use case is
transformation
of secrets or other types of objects. For
example,
if you have some operator that creates a
Postgres password and username, you might need
that information somewhere else
in a JDBC
URL, for example.
So you can use that as an input
and create another secret that has a different
form of that secret,
which is very helpful,
especially for cross plane stuff
or the AWS
Kubernetes operators and so on.
Wow. So, yeah, that's a sneak preview. Maybe
we can, if if you're interested, have a
session just for that topic.
Yeah. Definitely. I think what would be really
interesting for us to do is obviously just
to get another session where we show the
preview environment based on a new pull request
and the comment and stuff like that. Yep.
But then, you know, the first time that
popped into my head as soon as I've
seen those those list of kind of I
don't know if you got them plug ins
or extensions,
but like how difficult would it be for
me to integrate that with another source? Like,
could I build preview environments based on tweaks?
Like, I think we could have some fun
than random shit there.
Definitely.
The idea is really the object
template,
so the
most important resource that this controller provides,
does not care what it loads.
It really here, it can load everything. So
if you come up with a controller operator
that loads tweets,
you can use the result of that here
without any the template controller.
Okay. I'm on it. I'm gonna make that
happen.
Nice.
Alright. Cool.
Okay.
Let's pop back over.
Mhmm. Yeah.
Alright. We covered a lot there. I had
no idea, but that that last set of
features either. That's that's wild. I can't believe
all that already exists. And it's only been
twelve months since we lasted the the demo.
So again, great work on this project and
it's it's just nice to see a bit
of alternatives,
but not just alternatives to this to this
call, but super powerful and flexible alternatives
just to score. So cool.
Alright.
Is that coming soon? Is that already available
for people to play with? And what what
else have you got on the the pipeline
for Kluctl?
So all this is already available. It's all
released, all usable.
All Kluctlr related is, I think, quite stable,
so I'm confident to use it in production.
Template controller,
yes, you can use it, but it's still
alpha, I would say, but still already
very powerful.
So what's in the pipeline?
The WebUI needs a lot of improvements.
The problem is I'm
not a UI designer. I'm also not good
at HTML,
CSS, JavaScript and all that.
I can do the most basic stuff, and
it was
with the help of some freelancers that I
hired. It was enough to implement
the WebUI.
But there's a lot that I wish that
I could finish in the next months.
For example, multi cluster support so that you
have one single instance of the WebUI managing
and visualizing
all your clusters.
That's something.
What else?
Yeah. Most of the stuff, Kluctlr related, is
actually just details,
like small features that need to be added.
I know you are asking for OCI integration
since quite some time, so that's maybe something
I should
actually tackle,
and it's not so complicated. I just need
to find time for that.
And it's Yeah. Just to context
Sorry. Hey. Just to add context to that.
Like, the reason that's important
to me is that I'm a big I
I use a lot of mono repositories.
Mhmm. And I like my Kubernetes YAML
to live as close to the application itself,
which means I have a mono repository
with dozens to hundreds of services all with
their own YAML. And
sure way that I could have Kluctl pull
in the entire model repository. And I'm sure
it does some great caching and only fetches
the latest version and stuff like that. Because
I just don't want all that code hanging
about in the cluster even though it's all
public either.
I think OCI is a great way of
being able to keep the developer workflow happy
and still satisfy the machines at runtime. So,
yeah, I would love to see that feature.
I know.
I said it's
in my head, I have it kind of
solved. It's really it's not complicated.
But the time. I mean Of course. Currently,
the state is still, when it comes to
developing and maintaining the project, it's mostly me.
Some it gets some checks. Some people are
showing up and implementing
smaller features. I hope it gets more. I
need support
as much as I can get contributors.
So, yeah, time is the limiting factor.
It would be just me deciding that I
would just work on Clue CDL. But
Well, hopefully, the people that tune in to
the previous episodes on this episode, their interest
has peaked. They can start to adopt the
control within their teams or organization,
and of course, contribute back whenever possible. So
definitely get involved and check out the GitHub
repository.
Is there anything else you would like to
share with us before we wrap up today's
session?
Can you repeat? Is there anything else you
would like to say, share?
I don't know. Before we before before
we say goodbye.
I think I've said said all.
Alright. So thanks for having me again. Thanks
for listening.
I know people get out. Definitely my
pleasure, and I hope that everyone else that
watches this is excited by the project as
I am. Some fantastic updates, and I can't
wait to do another episode and whenever that's
gonna be. So we'll we'll work that out
on a Discord. But Yep. Thank you for
joining me. Thank you for everyone that's watching.
We'll be back again soon, and have a
great day.
Thanks.
Bye bye.